at the time of Moses we would say they
were submitters to God they were Muslim
and they were doing Islam submission to
the will of God it's all about
submitting to God it's the essence of
religion is to submit and obey God God
didn't ordain Judaism God did not ordain
Christianity but we know as Muslims
Allah did ordain Islam and perfected it
as the faith of the Believers it's the
straight path all the prophets and
Messengers came for a segment of
humanity except the last one peace be
upon them
Muhammad was sent and his duty his
mission was to all Humanity monotheism
not to worship idols not to and to and
that was that's why I became Muslim
because I saw it clear as day after
living the life I lived Allah took me
around the block a few times and I could
see it clear as day that Islam was home
for a
believer